رياح السياسه التركيه تهب بعيدا عن حركه
حماس رياح تسريب علاقات انقره مع تل ابيب
في مجرى بعيد عن اهوى الحركه زياره رئيس
الاسرائيلي لانقره في مارس الماضي حملت
معها مطالبه لتركيا بابعاد حماس وقادتها
عن اراضيها طلبات اسرائيل لم تلقى استجابه
تركيه حينها لكن تقارير افادت بان السلطات
التركيه بدات مؤخرا في تجديد القيود على
تحركات قيادات حماس باراراضها انقر الى
حتى هذه اللحظه ما زالت ترفض هذه الضغوط
الاسرائيليه ولكنها تقوم بزاويه اخرى
بالتضيق وتقييد حركه همم القيادات القادمه
من الخارج داخل الى داخل تركيا وحتى
المقيمين من عناصر القيادات حماس وهنا في
الداخل عده تقارير اكدت ان انقره بدات
بالحد من ظهور قاده في تركيا وعدم السماح
لقيادات من الصف الاول او اقل بالمجيء الى
تركيا بقصد الاقامه انما بزيارات قصيره
للمشاركه في مؤتمرات او اجتماعات ويرى
متابعون ان السياسه حكومه حزب العداله
والتنميه الجديده تجاه حماس لا ترتبط فقط
بعمليه التطبيع لكن ايضا باهم استحقاق
داخلي هذا العام الا وهو الانتخابات
في هذا الموضوع الانتخابات تقترب لذلك
الحكومه استداره الخلف في سياستها
الخارجيه وتحاول اعطاء رسائل من اجل ارساء
السلامه واقامه علاقات جديده وتركز تركيا
على شخصيات لها ارتباط عسكري بحماس حيث
ذكرت وسائل اعلام ان السلطات ابعدت 10
اشخاص قبل فتره ما ترك عناصر الحركه في
حاله حلق
صعوبه منح اقامات لعدد كبير منهم لا شك ان
علاقه تركيا بحماس لن تكون كما كانت عليه
قبل تطليع العلاقات مع تل ابيب صحيح ان
انقر لن تستجب لمطالب الاسرائيليين
بالتخلي الكامل عن حماس لكن الساحه
التركيه لن تعود من الان فصاعدا مجال
الرحبا لقاده الحركه وفق ما يراه كثير
زيدان زينجو العربيه اسطنبول